heute stellen wir euch das präfix ab vor
es gibt im deutschen viele wörter mit
dem präfix ab zum beispiel ablegen
abstellen abstand das präfix steht also
immer am anfang von einem wort und es
gibt dem wort ganz oft eine bestimmte
bedeutung ab bedeutet so was wie weg von
mein mann macht etwas weg von einem von
etwas ab kann auch heißen dass man eine
distanz herstellt oder eine trennung
passiert hier sind ein paar beispiele
der abstand zwischen janisch und kari
gibt es einen großen abstand der
abschied wenn man sich verabschiedet
dann sagt man tschüss und man trennt
sich von einander
das verb verabschieden hat sogar zwei
präfix entscheiden bedeutet trennen
abschieden heißt so was wie voneinander
trennen und sich verabschieden dass fehr
kann man nicht direkt übersetzen aber
zusammen bildet ist dieses verb und es
bedeutet dass man sich schuss sagt die
abfahrt eine abfahrt gibt es zum
beispiel auf der autobahn und ab fahren
bedeutet dass man den ursprünglichen weg
verlässt und dann nimmt man eine abfahrt
zum beispiel ich nehme die abfahrt
nummer 9 und die abfahrt geht nach
münchen
das präfix ab steht auch oft am anfang
von verben und man kann sich merken dass
all diese werben mit abtrennbare werben
sind ein trend bares wert bedeutet dass
der erwerb stamm konjugiert wird und
dieser konjugierte werkstatt steht am
anfang eines satzes und das präfix also
das ab steht dann immer am ende des
hauptsitzes hier ein paar beispiele
abmachen janus hat einen aufkleber auf
dem rücken
ich mache den aufkleber abbiegen biegen
ist sowas wie tubandt und wenn man
abwägt dann geht man weg von dem
ursprünglichen weg und geht zu einer
ecke janus fährt fahrrad
er biegt nach rechts ab ablehnen kari
bietet janisch ein kaugummi an janisch
lehnt ab abwaschen janisch hat sieben
tassen kaffee getrunken
jetzt muss er die tassen erstmal
abwaschen damit er wieder saubere hat
janisch wäscht den teller ab oder
janisch spült die tasse ab und jetzt hat
janisch den abwasch gemacht jetzt
trocknet janosch das geschirr ab wenn
man etwas abtrocknet dann benutzt man
das tuch so dass das wasser danach weg
ist man trocknet ab jetzt kommen wir zum
fortgeschrittenen teil es gibt auch
einige werben mit abdi nicht mehr diese
ursprüngliche bedeutung haben dass etwas
einfach nur wörtlich weg geht und es
gibt sogar einige werben die auch doppel
bedeutungen oder sogar mehrere
bedeutungen haben
hier sind ein paar beispiele ablaufen
man läuft eine strecke ab dass benutzt
man vor allem wenn man etwas sucht
janisch hat seine brille im mauerpark
verloren er läuft den ganzen park ab um
die brille zu suchen ablaufen kann auch
bedeuten dass eine zeit zu ende geht
janisch hat einen timer gesetzt der
timer läuft ab die milch steht im
kühlschrank sie läuft in drei tagen ab
machen ab machen kann man ganz wörtlich
verstehen wir haben gerade schon das
beispiel janisch macht den aufkleber von
seiner jacke ab machen kann jedoch auch
bedeuten dass man einen termin
vereinbart
kari wollen wir nächste woche zusammen
einen film gucken klar wollen wir direkt
einen termin abmachen ja gerne
mir würde es am besten am donnerstag
oder am freitag passen donnerstag halb
neun
abgemacht abbrechen abbrechen kann man
ganz wörtlich verstehen
janosch bricht ein stück von seinem keks
ab er nimmt ein stück vom keks weg
abbrechen kann jedoch auch bedeuten dass
etwas zu ende geht
ich kann zum beispiel sagen heute ist es
kalt wir brechen den dreh deshalb jetzt
abhängen abhängen kann man ganz wörtlich
verstehen wieder
ich hänge das bild an die wand und ich
hänge das bild wieder abhängen von kann
jedoch auch bedeuten dass etwas nicht
ohne etwas anderes funktioniert das
hängt davon ab heißt es kommt darauf an
was machen wir morgen gefeiert
ich weiß es nicht das hängt davon ab
morgen das wetter wird abhängen kann
jedoch auch ein slang seien dafür dass
man einfach irgendwo ohne ziel rumhängt
oder abhängt und eine gute zeit hat
janisch hängt auf dem sofa ab und guckt
videos abgeben kann bedeuten dass man
etwas weg gibt janisch gibt mir immer
die hälfte von allem ab abgeben kann
jedoch auch bedeuten dass man etwas ganz
weg bringt zum beispiel kann ich sagen
ja es gibt jetzt diesen brief bei der
post ab oder morgen gebe ich meine
masterarbeit ab
das war unser video zum präfix ab und
wir hoffen euch haben die beispiele
heute gefallen
wenn ihr mehr grammatische fragen habt
dann schreibt sie uns hier unten und
dann können wir vielleicht auch
demnächst ein video darüber machen was
ihr euch gerne wünscht schreibt uns also
gerne eure vorschläge und wenn ihr lust
habt deutschlands strukturiert zu lernen
die vokabeln und die grammatik ganz
strukturiert von a1 bis b2 zu lernen
dann schaut euch doch mal unsere apps an
dort könnt ihr unter anderem die 6.000
wichtigsten vokabeln lernen die ihr
braucht um das b2 level zu erreichen
tschüss und bis bald
[Musik]
[Applaus]